hey everyone its sail with registered
nurse orange calm and in this video
we're going to go over Jackson Pratt
drains also called JP drains for short
in this video I'm going to give you a
comprehensive overview what you can
expect from a JP drain whenever you're
taking care of one as a nurse and this
is what I'm going to talk about I'm
going to go over what a JP drain is I'm
going to show you one go over all of its
parts with you how to care for one as a
nurse which will include emptying it and
milking it how to keep it secure and
assessing the site I'm also going to
talk about how you should document
whenever you're taking care of one and
talk to you about the potential
complications you may experience with
one and how the troubleshooting one so
the very first thing I want to do is I
want to show you a picture here in a
second a picture is going to pop up and
it's a picture of three JP drains what
you're going to see is you're going to
see a little hand grenade JP drain
that's what we call them us nurses
because they look like a little hand
grenade and it'll be in the front and
then behind it will be a larger hand
grenade a JP drain and then over to the
side will be it looks a little bit like
a recording it has little springs in it
and you squish it down and that will be
over on your left so let's take a look
at those
okay now that you've seen what JP drains
look like in the hospital setting what
you'll actually encounter let me show
you this drawing that I've drawn of a
little Hand Grenade one that you will
see in the hospital technically this is
the most commonly one I've seen and I've
blown it up this is not how big it is
I've won it up to scale so you can see
it and I'm going to go over its all of
its little parts with you and show you
how it is because it's so important you
know every little nook and cranny in
every little part on a drain so you can
be familiar with it so let's zoom in and
take a look at this okay what you're
seeing right here this top area is the
insertion part where the surgeon
inserted the drain these JP drains are
most commonly found on patients whose
height who've had thoracic surgeries or
abdominal surgeries and they'll insert
the drain inside the womb and this will
drain all the drainage that's collected
in the surgical wound out because you
don't want this drainage setting inside
the surgical site and it will drain down
into this bulb so how does it drain down
into the bulb what causes it to drain
down the bulb is that this part right
here you can press it and whenever you
can press it it causes suction which
will suck all this stuff out and as all
this drainage is coming down through the
tube it will collect in this collection
area right here and it will expand the
bulb out and once it's expanded out it
won't suck any more drainage and you'll
have to empty it and a lot of times you
want to empty this whenever it's halfway
full so this is a hundred CC collection
chamber so you want to empty it whenever
it hits about 250 CC so how do you empty
it you have on this area a removable cap
with a port so this area comes off and
just like a little pop off cap and it
will stay once you pop it off and
there's a pore and you just turn it
upside down and squeeze it into a
measuring cup to get your drainage and
it's easy because you can measure it and
then right here sometimes physicians
will have an order for you to remove
or the physician will do it themselves
but there's usually two to three little
black sutures here that you have to get
a little suture kit and remove those and
after you remove the sutures the drain
literally just slides out a little glide
out I don't know if you've ever removed
a Foley catheter or a PICC line or
anything like that but that's how gentle
it comes out whenever you do that now
let's go over all the technical details
about a JP drain and how you provide
care to it and document in the potential
complications
okay there's many different types of
drains and usually you have open system
drains and you have closed system drains
a JP drain is a closed system drain that
uses bulb suction remember you compress
the bulb and it prevents all that
drainage from where the surgeon operated
from pulling around that surgical site
and it collects it just nicely down in
this bowl now what's the benefits of a
closed system drain compared to an open
system drain an open system drain just
to give you an example is like a Penrose
drain and I'll be going over that a
little bit later but what happens is
whenever you have a Penrose drain you
have this drain sticking out of the
surgical wound and you just have this
dressing around it and it just collects
around that which increases the chance
of infection and you can't really
measure that drainage very well so a JP
drain allows you to keep track of your
drainage and decreases the risk of
infection because it's not just pulling
around the wound so that's the benefits
of a closed system drain so how do you
care for a JP drain as a nurse
now there's Hospital protocols that each
facility has they may require little
technical details a little bit
differently so always check with the
place you're working for before you mess
with a JP drain if you're not familiar
with it but this is generally what
you're going to be doing to it as a
nurse
okay first emptying it this is so
important okay you want to empty this
drain whatever it's halfway full this is
usually about one to two times a day and
what you do after you empty it you'll
record it this is so important because a
lot of surgeons are going to ask you hey
how much is that JP drain putting out
and you'll tell them or they can easily
look on a flow sheet in the computer but
usually they ask you because that's the
easiest thing for them to do is ask you
and you'll have to know and they will
usually discontinue these drains if
they've put out less than thirty CCS in
a 24-hour period so it's very important
you're documenting and measuring this
accurately so what type of drainage can
you expect in these drains typically if
it's a fresh strain that's put in
they're coming to you post off they've
literally had surgery just 24 hours ago
you're going to be seeing bloody
drainage which is called serous
sanguinis fluid it's going to be serous
fluid mixed with blood then as the wound
starts to heal it's going to go to light
pink then to light yellow then to clear
now what's not normal what type of
drainage do you need to watch out for
typically whenever you start having
cloudy yellow or a tan color maybe even
sometimes green and it has a really bad
odor this is high indication that there
is an infection going on and if that was
the case you want to immediately let the
surgeon know that okay you found this
and it might be an infection so how do
you entertain let's go over it one more
time because I think you can never go
over things too much especially if
you're new to it so let's talk about how
you empty it again so you have your
little grenade and like I said you empty
it when it's halfway full or whatever
your Hospital says one to two times and
what you do is you take your little cap
off you pop it off and the ball will
inflate if it's not ready inflated and
then you'll pour the contents out into a
measuring cup a lot of hospitals have
these clear little measuring cups that
have little numbers on the side that say
1 CC 2 CCS I really recommend that you
pour those in there to measure properly
and then dispose of it usually you can
just flush it down the toilet but if
your hospital has a protocol for that if
they're in contact or has some type of
MRSA or something in it they may require
that you do something different with it
but generally you can just flush it down
the toilet and then you'll want to clean
this little plug area that you popped
off with just some alcohol prep because
you want to decrease in
faction so after you pop it off just
clean it and then pop it back on and
then before you pop it back on though
compress your bulb so you can have
suction going back in so clean the
little plug compress it it'll look like
a little donut that a little hole will
form from where it's been compressed so
much and then put your plug back on and
then it's ready to go they're really
simple and easy to take care of it's one
of my favorite dreams now let's talk
about milking the drain what is that
exactly
okay milking a drain what it does is it
helps prevent clots from forming in this
little tubing section right here because
if this tubing section because you know
how it's draining drainage from this
insertion site which has blood in it
blood clots because it has clotting
cells in it this little tube means I can
get clotted now what does it look like
whenever you have a potential clot
you'll see some like dark stringy areas
inside the tubing that's a good
indication hey some clots are wanting to
form so milky and the tubing allows you
to prevent this from happening because
if this happens you'll notice that and
all of a sudden you won't get as much
drainage or sometimes there's a dressing
around this insertion site will become
saturated things like that so how do you
actually milk the tubing what you want
to do is you want to take one of your
hands fingers with your thumb and your
finger and you want to just hold it up
at where the insertion site is this is
keeping it secure then you're going to
take your other finger and you're just
going to your thumb and your index
finger and you're just going to gently
just compress it down into the compress
into the collection chamber so in a
sense you're just taking the tubing and
you're just sort of squeezing it down
and just stripping it in a sense down
into the collection chamber to get all
that fluid and stuff out of there so it
doesn't form a clot now what a hospital
protocols will order you to do this
every four hours so always document that
you're milking the tubing and that
you've been doing this just in case
something happens and someone can't come
back and say hey you weren't milking the
tubing per protocol that's why you got a
clots are always document
that and like I said the clots will
appear dark red and stream now okay
another thing just some side notes you
want to keep this drain secure
especially if your patients up moving a
lot of times after surgery if it wasn't
a huge major surgery where they can't
get up and be mobile we want the
patients up and moving and a lot of
times these little JP drains will have
collect little secured tags on them and
you can put a safety pin and pin it to
their gown a lot of times that some
hospitals may carry this I don't know if
your hospital will but and I don't know
if you're familiar with what the Foley
catheter secure device looks like it's
like a little Tegaderm and it has a
little velcro part and you can just put
it around the tubing just keeps it in
place there's things similar to that and
you always whatever you do secure it
don't take the drain and secure it up at
the top because it's not going to drain
you want to keep it below the insertion
site so gravity and the bulb suction
suction can work together and pull that
down so keep it secure because you don't
want to be pulled out even though these
sutures will help keep that in place
sometimes those sutures like to wear out
and the drain will slip out which won't
be good and next you'll want to always
assess what the cert what the insertion
site looks like around the drain very
important so right here there's an
insertion site and you want to look at
that skin around it what you're looking
for is any signs of infection and if
there's a dressing around there always
make sure you're keeping it dry and
you're changing it regularly because if
you keep a dressing in place and it's
wet that increases the chances of
infections so signs of infection would
be the area's red it's warm it's tender
to the patient it could also feel hard
or it could have swelling so make sure
you look for that now let's talk about
documenting a lot of times your hospital
will have a flow sheet that you will use
to document about your Jaypee drains but
sometimes you don't so you can either
write this in a progress note using the
format that your hospital wants or a
document at wherever you're supposed to
document it and you'll want to include
that you emptied it what it what the
drainage look
like that you emptied how much it was if
you performed milking or not and what
the insertion site look like and if you
secured the drain or not so those are
some important things you want to record
now let's talk about potential
complications some potential
complications you have to watch out for
are the following
typically clot formation like I
discussed earlier and usually what will
happen is if you suspect clot formation
is that you will notice that there will
be no drainage in the bulb or you will
see a decrease in drainage or the
drainage will be around the insertion
site instead of the bulb now if this
happens and your Mill and you milk the
tubing and that didn't work then you'll
want to notify the doctor next the
catheter falls out remember that a
little tubing area this is this extends
into the wound sometimes what happens is
those little sutures they work their way
off and it can slip out and if this
happens of course you want to notify the
doctor immediately and just place a
bandage over the area just to keep it
free from any infections or anything
like that until you get further orders
on what to do and then lastly sometimes
what you might have happen is that
whenever you say you empty the bowl or
you notice you go in to assess your
patient the bulbs and inflated and
you're going to go compress it because
maybe the previous person forgot to and
compress it and the bulb won't compress
usually what's happened is that there's
a clot that has formed or the catheter
has become dislodged and if this happens
of course you'll want to notify the
doctor and see what he wants to do about
it
so that is an overview about JP drains
what you'll have to know as a nurse I
hope this helped increase your knowledge
and you can take it back to clinical
practice and put it to use and thank you
so much for watching and be sure to
check out my other videos on nursing
skills and have a great day